what is your favorite pixar movie
i like up i'm gonna tell you why i like
up you know now that's a hard question
it's hard not to say toy story right i i
didn't think that they could ever
top the emotional depth that was inside
out
when i first saw that man it just took
me to a place
in my childhood like i want to go on a
journey with him and he reminded me a
little bit of michael mann
i think i'm gonna i'm gonna say toy
story amy would probably want you to say
inside out
but out is also it's my yes it's
a tie how is he like michael mann
the way the guy looks okay okay yeah
yeah the way you look yeah not not named
personality okay okay i don't know if
you i don't know if you get direct in
the incredible film but yeah
in the first 17 minutes of up first of
all when i hear pixar my
my ears perk right because i know oh
okay this is going to mean something
[Music]
still
i mean not only is it going to look good
and not only am i going to enjoy it
but it's going to mean something it's
always hard for me to tell you this is
my favorite okay
you know in 2020 a lot of us are just
wrestling with
the crossroads of what is our life like
are we are we happy are we fulfilled
and you know even though
i know that you know the delay of the
film is sort of might be
seen as disappointing or whatnot but no
i think it's almost
it could have been more timely and
better for this film to come out on
[Music]
christmas